But everywhere, the natural world is
bursting with backstories. The world is
made of—or more precisely, by—time. This is what I mean by timefulness: an
awareness of the rich natural history
that envelops us, a sense that we too live
in geologic time and are part of a
continuum from the planet's past into its
future. Timefulness is a deliberate
counterpoint to timelessness—an
unattainable, sterile, and, I will argue,
even dangerous idea. But we live in a
time-illiterate society, as I don't need to tell this audience. We would be
shocked if an educated adult had no
idea where the continents were on a
global map, but don't seem bothered by the fact that few average people have a
good sense of the geography of the
planet's past, even though we will spend
our entire lives here. We behave like bad tourists on earth, enjoying its amenities
and ransacking its bounty, without ever having noticed that it has its own
ancient language and customs. Many of the environmental problems we face have
arisen because we collectively lack a sense for the duration of chapters in
Earth's history, the rates of geologic
processes like groundwater flow, or the
intrinsic timescales of natural
phenomena like climate change.